the fossa Academy Award I got was for
Empire Strikes Back I never thought my
future I'd see very many awards if any
at all it was a fantasy you know it's
something that didn't apply to certainly
to me doing you know these crazy little
effects scenes that I did you know who
would who would appreciate those
the Academy says I've got nine Oscars
I've got eight of the statuettes and one
is detecting what sheep an award for and
go motion the first one I got I kept in
a drawer for a year because I just
didn't believe it it's sort of like that
that old Wayne's World thing of you know
I'm not worthy the Oscars are all over
the place there are family friends have
them they sort of go out for people who
want to who want to use them and show
them off a stuff like that now I spread
them around they always come back I
worked on the it see Star Wars now it's
called episode 4 episode 5 it was a six
episode one a little bit episode two on
Jurassic Park Terminator 2 the abyss
Spielberg's War of the Worlds Indiana
Jones the Temple of Doom et I started
doing this stuff when I was about six or
seven years old
and at that time you know I just wanted
to recreate scenes I've seen the movie
so I got plastic dinosaurs and my dad's
still camera which you of course had to
learn how to use to take a photo of the
dinosaur so look like you're making a
movie about a dinosaur but to me it that
never seemed like it was going to amount
to anything
but it absolutely did amount everything
well I was starting out there were very
few special effects being done at all
and then along came you know Star Wars
the technology was so new and so we all
learned there for the first year we were
on the show what to do with this motion
control equipment how to make it work
how to create these shots that nobody
had seen before with this early computer
system on Star Wars I was turning out
shots that were different so instead of
doing a shot the X been flying through
the trench I turned that into a shot
looking at the x-wing and moving the
camera into the cockpit in r32 that was
not asked for so when it comes up in
dailies you know I remember George Lucas
saying you know well I never knew you
could do you turn a shot into something
like that
and we did geraci part that just knocked
people up and you know we called out the
shock of the new I'm nobody had seen it
before we haven't seen it before
anything to look that realistic and I
think in the time since then
everything's gotten a lot more realistic
and the audiences have gotten used to it
the worker can knock look as authentic
and real unless you take your time to
really study reality study lighting
study organic object study man-made
objects and all that and then apply it
to the movies you're doing if you're
doing fantasy scenes they still need to
be rooted in valley
as far as give me the awards it's an
amazing experience going to the Academy
Awards you know I probably been to 15 of
them I just don't know how to really how
to explain it it's something you just
never expect and being a nominee we get
great seats